after all we're sorry for the technical
issues we had with the yesterday's game
which was an exciting game and will I
think Chris we're going to try and do
that at some point in the future again
that game 7 yeah it was somewhat unlucky
it's a it's a bit we had set up here
because i'm on a notebook and also not
with a steady internet connection is
just a mobile phone connection so that
seemed to really worsen the audio a lot
but we invested some time yet trying to
to make it better for this video yeah
some think we should do again at at
another time it was an interesting game
strategically so it's a bit it's a bit a
bit of a shame that they're all you
really am yeah it's a problematic of
this game yeah yeah okay let's get going
with the maids it was an exciting game i
think this match finally has got yeah
yeah I've got off the ground so and I'm
flying white against girlfriend he plays
d4 and then we see Knight f6 nothing
unusual so far well Knight f6 instead of
the Slav we see a tendency to once maybe
the groom field now after c4 g6 um yeah
it's kind of interesting for I think
because um yeah girlfriends much
strategy seems to be to on to impress
some on a very very very solid basis
with white those kind of slice was III
and this little things which really a
letter win last game and with black he
really plays dynamic openings he plays
your green fault he played this freshly
cough and the kind of swap stuff in
contrast to what he often also plays
stuff like the petrol for he plays his
love as well but in this match he wants
for whom fold another dynamic opening
sentence yeah Hannah sticks with 2 X 3
here which the movie already played in
Game three I guess yeah actually I
remember as well as you mention in the
previous video
and it been played before I think
sheriff has a YouTube video where he was
afraid of kramnik playing this and not
wanting to transpose into a Kings Indian
defense I think anyway there's it's
interesting that this has been used in
the past this f3 as well quite a lot
sometimes avoiding the Greenfield main
line but now we see c5 black
counter-attacking on the dark squares
you know interestingly enough Oh Agatha
doesn't want to go into this d5 set up
again which he had in Game three he had
some problems in Game three on it was I
guess close to getting something really
young significant in this game he had an
extra porn but someone couldn't ya find
the way to to make it count and now
instead of d5 sec 5 which transport us
to kind of a benoni setup but with the
slight twist that we will see um ya
shortly so what goes to five yep d5 and
so it looks as though well so a kind of
okay sie mich Kings engine wear black
you know in theory can celebrate the
dark squares but uh it's it's tricky in
fact in this position I think this is a
very interesting move nighty too already
so the night can can come this night can
come to see free potentially that that's
quite interesting move night laughs it's
very probably it's very yeah but it's
really a kind of an onion uncommon
position here already um but it makes a
lot of sense of course because the night
on g1 is White's a problem peace and all
those f three setups and as usual
usually you get setups with the nite b 2
c 3 and yeah it's difficult to to get
this night developed and what he's doing
now after castles week i think we can
put it on the board Oh
Castle snow as you there's just one
thing I want to say that I think I think
so I've had a game as white where I've
waited for 97 and sneaked in night age
32 f 2 which which was which took okay
but that doesn't have to happen black
doesn't have to play Knight d7 and now
this mover but no daddy seven would be
quite an inaccurate move I guess to to
allow an idea tree black really should
allow this move because this is really
the problem wyd some does this on change
e2 to d5 is very very pleasing to the
eye it's very stable but it really
little bit close up this King site
development yeah so there's the famous
saying that the same ish is a good
opening but ask the night on g1 watching
things about it did another I didn't
know that fibers users make the up
really you know is if I decide in your
chess club no no no no no no and I
cannot really put it to some it's some
famous player said that i'm not quite
sure maybe neither off or whatever some
some great player from the party was a
bit critical about the same ish
variation okay so 92 castles and now at
each OC 3 and this is really a point
where this some somewhat original move
forward with f3 early and yeah this may
be beneficial to wide as he um easily
can put this night on a good square this
be one night of course looks a bit
redundant at the moment but it can go to
g52 later or maybe a three at some point
yeah make sense some of a mirror image
of a french tarish where the night's
dancing round on the Kings side yeah it
makes a lot of sense the only issue here
you could be the White has got lots of
pieces on the queenside and he doesn't
have much on the king so but this makes
a lot of sense to make use of this so
I'm bit surprised that gay adults
initiated the c5 setup also so early on
move three
could have also played Bishop g7 castles
g6 before and see if white would go the
same way again black in this game and
maybe then back has some other setup I'm
not sure if I assume that a 68 is a bit
risky here because if you give white c4
then night a free to c4 or night d this
would be very useful maybe for this
night yeah could be it could be um maybe
you're sick so he doesn't didn't want to
play because of this implication but
it's difficult to generate any play with
Audi six yeah if you just hang around
with Blackie oh you're just in a bed
linen II and I mean the bin only per se
the structures is bad from like you need
to get some activity going otherwise
you're just worse I know you usually a
mink you crush me and blitz usually with
this structure sometimes taking on e5
Farah it's horrible yeah so so here
actually black now plays Knight h5 which
looks as though it's got Anna Griffin
aggressive intention of f5 um at some
point but um and I'm honest with you I
don't understand to move I have no idea
what it's doing well technically it does
make way for love it yeah f4 f5 it looks
a bit from attic if you get a good grip
on the dark squares that'll be good
wouldn't it if you can get a nice night
on 85 we're better porn on a fool and
maybe maybe he wants to really play a
five and i'm not sure or he wants to
maybe play I'm not sure FF five looks
terribly a committal but ok it's an idea
maybe two to open up the position while
white has made lots of pawn moves and
lots of night moves then why does not
very well developed if you see basically
almost all his pieces still on the first
rank so many tries to open up the
position quickly but well white could've
gone g4 here for instance and you just
need to drop back then
but it would have been an idea but it's
of course also very committed from
White's point of view as you now me to
get will coincide with the king or leave
it in the center for some way it would
would have been playable I guess but
maybe not the kind of move that Island
was up to I think it's Bishop g5 was was
finest wall well actually when I'm white
against Simon sure I used to play I used
to enjoy the white side I like having a
night here so when you play g5 this
night can't go there so I guess g5 has
less venom here if maybe night h5 is
possible again yeah i think the
stiffness kinda g4 here would be more to
gain spaceman to really am trying to
attack the king yeah it's very debatable
if it's a good move angeles just
mentioned mentioning it because it was
also mentioned in the press conference
but iono didn't really answer the
question if he seriously considered this
move somehow he danced around the n-side
didn't say anything so my Bishop g5 form
makes lots of sense developing this
piece preventing e6 yes and sort of
asking you slacker what would i doing
next year in this position and a camel
we came up with a really a really
interesting with mission at six yes
usually a king's engine plot doesn't
want to give up their dark square Bishop
that easily because you are weakening
more your squares around the king yeah
it's just one thing which I which
immediately popped into mind when I was
watching the game on oh if you don't
know it's useful to know that girl found
one he played in recent years he played
the Slav and other openings he's
originally he's injured and Bologna
player and its use it's it's not like
it's never had this kind of positions
before yeah and also on he's gotten his
former trainer in his charms one year
and was told when he was not meaningless
really at its former trainer is some
system of
all that carbon would the name is a
famous expert on the same ish and also
this benoni kind of structures and they
wrote a book together on black 15 to 20
years ago ah and all this kind of the
moon set up so it's not by variances
playing this for the first time in his
life also so he should have somebody do
what she's doing in these positions yeah
but sugar sticks this treaty a
surprising move but i think it was
interesting because yeah why does some
inclined to take here yeah I wouldn't
really hmm I mean it's weakening little
the dark squares being celebrated a bit
more with the absence of this Bishop
yeah so it gives you to a pause to
unbreak up the center yeah whatever i
was wandering around while I handle but
what's wrong with wiper just got a 33
here just going back a free yeah this
would be the first moved a little point
in bed maybe then steadily better stop
asking never i doing with your night on
one HR recognition 106 I'm just ignored
in the pieces what I even doing hey I'm
not sure it's a very very reposition
yeah I'm sure what is doing really what
saying that in his madness to be I just
understanding the kind of a.m. Becca
school I if there's no commitment for f5
here without f5 I don't see say he goes
back he's just lost the tempo then
hasn't he he's given white free move now
for Queen d2 say if you're into each one
you'll just be very nervous yeah that's
kind of led to which we go back and
don't move hmm I would have considered
method unfortunately no one asked them
in the press conference about this move
maybe there should be three lectures go
see six and continues that's possible
right yeah this piece is on f6 and h5
are somewhat weird but it's not like you
immediately have an idea how to how to
use this may be it so can share
is not so bad to force G free and then
later fi might have more impact so Force
jet oh I don't know maybe maybe maybe
this is completely absurd but which may
be a record yeah I think I think I've
it's white smooth but black hoods could
maybe go each five instead of six just
just a completely different idea with
the idea of of playing Bishop g5 but
Queen d2 red which preventers if black
will get in Bishop g5 but now this is
useful for night g7 this is checked
benoni territory and then you can go
like this you can go you could try this
yeah but I think white would be very
very comfortable as this position but at
least it made a bit of logical sense to
facilitate night g7 yeah I'm trying to
make a bit of sense to this yeah but
maybe would have 36 we never know but
okay Alicia took on f6 which makes sense
as well of course it's not not like it's
totally surprising and then 22 checking
its away this Air Force we took the
poorly gives them potential pressure and
a hammering point on a four now if you
take to the night that just looks
passive right doesn't it yeah this is
yeah this looks like a white were half a
lot of fun deserve this afternoon yeah
okay so it's just a one-way street
position so it's dynamic compensation
which a lot of GM's they routinely
accept double pawns sometimes to get the
dynamic compensation and pressure um so
very often this kind of structures were
stubble poems which are part of let's
say I'm not quite sure how to phrase it
that are not isolated like if you have a
double form that say on the C file that
you don't have any porn and you don't
have a deep on there completely isolated
these are almost always weak but the
double points being part of so deferred
yeah let's say poor clump here on the
Queen don look inside the pool is no
equal said yeah let's say a pawn island
here yeah um this is no weakness at all
and usually very often it's even at what
strafford because you have enough open
file yes so it's there there even some
some players who who claim that often
double pawns I mean a big advantage to
have because you never open fast so
among the a black immediately goes for
at the f5 counterplay i like to call it
I don't know if it was a silly term but
I did like to call them potentially
losing trump cards because here okay
you've got this sort of trump card
generated but it's potentially losing
cause you've you've paid the price in
terms of structure so yeah it's sort of
give and take isn't it your you're
getting this but you you're taking my a
bit from your pawn structure as fatties
but if it's not significantly
exploitable then it's no big deal the
double forms and but yeah but this is a
big question now about white simply just
taking here on f5 which he did I don't
know what other options though what you
think about this e takes f5 was played
yeah I think like lettuce may be
threatening effort so maybe it was a
given that i also think i would have
taken there quickly oh yeah like my
treadmill for and then 925 yeah so he
takes a five and now walking into a
token folk he knows that you can take on
big one so this g4 okay but first they
can play check anyway so g4 is played
knowing that Bishop takes only one just
a funny thing i don't know if you saw
the press conference after the game
there they asked this year when did you
see the final position appearing in your
head the first time that you see if he
would play this way you would win the
game and he said when you played when
you played it takes five you did see the
final position blimey when he played
them the sites are five yeah yeah it's
pretty much force if you if you look at
it in in retrospect but um I know it's a
force because blech blundered on the way
but it's a plausible line to calculate
oh yes okay he play he went she fought
but I don't that does you
implications he's factoring in his own
weaknesses of the last move with the f
free and how black would take advantage
of that later yeah sure so that's a
mention that he's actually seen okay
what's coming okay well we won't spoil
it for this so there was a check thrown
in and now Bishop takes be one is
virtually forced there's no other way
otherwise the pieces are a fault here
yeah I think blegh needs to take the
rook takes p 1 and now okay so there's
the crossroads here the night could have
gone here or it could have gone there so
those illegal candidate moves but what
was chosen was Queen f6 so should we see
why so we just briefly mentioned why
Knight f6 wasn't engines right Knight f6
all night g 796 i think is the favorite
yeah i think okay the engine wants to
play this way because um the the other
the lion seen in the game just leads to
yeah big trouble for like and i think of
this I think if this is the moment then
don't like must play then the soul this
whole conception is just wrong because
some while white is not directly winning
or anything in this position Heath I
think he is got a very very nice stable
advantage that he can try to press home
White has just got a nice space
advantage with a pawn on d5 against you
six is typical benoni advantage and
black doesn't have her dark squared
Bishop yeah which can arrest white on
the dark square so the dark squares are
no problem here and 11 general issue
here is that blacks nights won't get any
good posts yeah this kind of f 3g for
setup limits the f6 Nigel this piece
doesn't do much and what white sir tries
to do in the long run is to play in the
g5 and m42 to really get a grip of the
key side and completely limit the lights
he wants to do this in a in a position
where black cannot go
9h 5 of course so this is a more of an
end game plan and ideally you would
would push all the kingside pawns but
why would try to exchange the heavy
pieces here and this issue is not so bad
you think it go to be free later and
support may be a king side attack or
something it's not theirs or breaks
isn't it like b5 is it's going to be
very hard bishop yeah this Bishop often
in the long run gets a very nice place
on h3h free it yeah this is where white
wants to go f four and 35 alright hit
the bishop on g4 or a tree or something
like this yeah you would get this kind
of this kind of position you very often
get them in in a line of the Kings
Indian the hava buck I've Ibaka line I'm
not sure how to pronounce it correctly
in English this kind of position you
would often get there but the only
difference being that there are still
the bishops on the board white would
have a bishop on on f4 and black one on
g7 and this is also acquired some quite
nice for what so it's not it's not
terrible completely terrible for black
but it's sort of position well you don't
have any counter play and you would
suffer for a long time yeah so it's
nothing he really would want to have on
the board so he really I think we will
he relied on Queen f6 and he also did
that when you played queen of sexy and
did calculate some pretty interesting
variations but incidentally in real life
playing a move like Queen f6 isn't that
like going through a blind alley way
where you you know you haven't got many
options along that alleyway you've just
turned off the main street and you know
that you're not going to have options
for quite a while and you've got to
precisely calculate that line haven't
you otherwise you know it's really
dangerous isn't it to go through a
forcing sequence oh yeah okay after this
is there snow nowhere beckoner yeah but
I think he just you just didn't see this
the final
coming and was thinking that he that he
had a good position really and there are
some lines which are very nice for black
no white takes on h5 but let's let's
quickly investigate an alternative which
is also interesting let's say why would
play we should be too hmm now and then
then I def form and ID form and this
this could be could be quite interesting
for white ah but yeah let's no it's not
it's not easy and now move like weenie
five white could could think about
various various options he could think
about a move like g5 with the idea of 96
whatever there are some ideas well what
gaffer wanted to do and he stated in the
press conference and what you intended
you wanted to take on you for here and
then 9075 our very nice blockade on the
dance class yeah I may be going g5 to
anchor this this night this kind of
lines beautiful position sacrifice yeah
it's very nice so he had some some good
ideas interesting ideas going yeah but
he simply miscalculated this kind of
landed him it just happened such what
can you do so basically it was just
taken yes just taken so the alleyway he
continues going up this alleyway where
his queen is now ending up on h1 ok and
here we assume he fought you're saying
island to me that Queen f4 was the
assumption yeah yeah in the press
conference and both player said that
they only thought about Queen f4 and
then I'm unsaid okay when he played he
takes a 5 he had this already in his
mind and then he saw already Queen f2 so
when then girlfriend played this Queen
f6e I think he almost instantly could
play the moves because he saw that that
he just wins here
dry after back asleep I'm news I don't
care so what game again Gavin also
couldn't that's no we're back as you
already mentioned yeah once your once
you're there you cannot go back it's
like going a dark anyway so Queen f2 now
why would they've initially fall so
Queen f2 and it seems the Queen well the
Queen he's kind of tracks unfortunately
it in a literal a sort of analogous
anyway as well not just from the forcing
line perspective but also the queen is
actually trapped down this anyway yeah
what wyd will move Bishop a tree or a d3
or whatever and just win the Queen and
it's a piece up then okay and he
actually resigns here but engines finds
a resource which is very interesting a
resource having which say Spassky once
in an otherwise completely hopeless
position i think Spassky plane and Kings
engine once played this spectacular type
of move when he was getting hacked on
the Kings side um I wonder if it's worth
mentioning it if youtubers can guess if
we give them 10 seconds it's it's not it
doesn't really save black but it would
maybe let let black play a few more
moves wonder if you guys on YouTube can
see it 10 seconds okay an engine move to
knight c6 Isaac it's really funnier and
i'm pretty sure that they're both i'm
not sure i cannot tell but it's easily
possible that that both players didn't
really take this into account and it
really as you said it darlin drew being
safe the day here but it saves the queen
yeah because if Bishop free there's
check and then there's another k check
on on f3 and then and then Queen takes
h2 is possible so that's the
ingeniousness of it but of course why is
best to take that night
and let the Queen escape at some cost
but here why it is better but two
engines it's about a pawn but it is it
is actually in practice and it you know
why it's got that d5 control we saw a
fascinating line where black sacrifices
the exchange world to be a bishop down
but it's at that level being a bishop
down for two pawns it's not very good um
yeah it all took place very nicely for
wide you can you can do various things
here 95 is a good idea of course you
could also think about just I'm just
seeing this right now maybe it's also an
idea play something like Bishop g2 to g5
and knight on e4 could also be a
worthwhile construction yeah so what
we'll get to get to you to tech most
likely on on blacks king while being
materially very fine but it's possible
that they really both didn't consider
the move and it's apparently I think
girl fam was annoyed of himself too much
so he just resigns hidden because he
didn't see this movie was annoyed I
thing good enough to yeah sony so what
was this queen f-for what why would both
of considered queen and what is it
because it attacks d6 as well as may be
threatening to trap you queen it's still
God's key squares but it doesn't mean
here Queen g1 is possible yeah yeah
maybe trust them okay you black needed
to see this basically one year when he
went for may even even before he went
Queen f6 really because what he needed
to learn maybe going back to f5 or
something because i think this Knight f6
on move 14 which you looked at which
leads to this really prospectus position
is something a black needs to avoid at
all costs so in pretty much yeah what's
down the drain quite valio he
Queen g1 it's not so terrible for black
because imagine you know he's got quindi
falls now he escapes here well queen
before yeah this is so this is fine but
she would the check even that this is
just escaping it okay so basically
unfortunately yeah so Queen f6 going
through this alley and finding it's not
very nice at the end of it unbelievable
it's quite a shocker I heard about it my
phone has a bit tied up earlier I
couldn't believe it off the yesterday's
game and apparently is a world record
you know almost a world record decisive
game for a world championship match this
one not only games are so few moves are
they no I don't think so there was a
very quick Earl awesome pre-famous game
also and but this wasn't a world
championship match it was it was
ineffective the world championship match
there was been a very quick loss by cap
off against Korchnoi in the nineteen
seventy-four match which decided to
would challenge Fisher so in effect it
was the World Championship match as fish
I didn't didn't play this in effect gave
camp a cup of the title the Caliph lost
one game also I think in in lighting or
18 moose or something it wasn't likewise
I seven or something yes right exactly
this yes i'ma my memories not so bad ya
know as a classic okay so i think i
might have videoed that at some point
that was really cool yeah yeah what's
the candidates final at the time so on
they have been quicker losses but yeah
this was really a quick but okay it's
not a matter that moves it's just it
were it got got concrete to concrete
calculation heavy position really early
and they will i think very early on
their own i think i'll move seven or
eight this is not home analysis anymore
they had to think on their own but you
don't isn't it hopeful amateur players
that they should compete against ions
and GM's with the idea that you know
they're not playing against computers
one day you know one of these irons or
GM's i know you're you're going to be an
item but for someone like me who's not
yeah i'm just seeing but you know I've
be beaten ever to ims but you okay a you
don't play them that much but there is
always the chance they will blunder and
this just demonstrates that they are
just human they're not anything like
computers tactically grandmas are just
people like us you know computers are
much stronger tactically aren't they
that and they're just going to get
stronger tactically as they see more
movies ahead each year yeah in positions
that are that are sharp interesting and
not one sided in a way if you got into
one sided position against the stronger
player where you're just suffering with
I don't know you don't have any space
you have a bed bishop whatever and you
don't really have play on your own then
it's very likely that you will suffer
against yeah a better player and maybe
lose but if you play your own game play
active and and aggressive moves yeah
then they will they will make mistakes
of course yeah this is and ok if you see
if you say you you've beaten only only
in in I'm not sure it's a 70 years yeah
in three days time control of course in
blade so you know it's much easier it's
every day everything else yeah but it's
also matter how many did you play if you
play like five four three two
tournaments a year with the nine games
each and you would play twenty im's each
year I guarantee you that you will be
three or four of them hmm yes it's it's
yeah it's it's just it just it will
happen and there are human you you if
you check your games with computers even
better players of Grand Master's you
will fear find lots of positions where
you could have played better or more
exact or whatever which not means that
the computers but when it just shows you
you get chances you get those chances
all the time I must admit in in recent
for in CL weekend it in one of the games
I video annotated a loss there was this
line where I could have actually trapped
my opponent screen and I even
miscalculated that but sometimes it's
very very important this idea of Queen
trapping if the opponent's queen is in
your territory to make sure
you can trap it or not I think that's a
critical thing in analysis because the
Queen's worth so much it's worth making
sure one hundred percent if it's trapped
or not and I I think this is an
important theme for you know club games
that this Queens entering magician so
can it be trapped or not they have to
make one hundred percent sure because
it's so valuable so here for instance in
this position here Queen f6 and white
needed to catch you later which form and
it's not difficult but you need to
calculate this line up to Queen f2 and
see okay this queen is trapped but
you're also you to do this if you don't
do it like what easily may we have the
better position yeah it's not like not
like UK okay I played some other move
and it's still a game or whatever now if
white doesn't go for this he maybe it's
worse with a strange down here isn't he
otherwise it's two rooks night it would
be he'll be the exchange down oh and
this white has this idea of mating but
that's not too slow isn't it um yeah
Queen f2 wins but it's the only move
that doesn't make your position worth I
guess so Queen g1 let's assume what does
try for that might andreea so you can
just go Queen III here and it's over I'm
Quinn Quinn f6 this Queenie five isn't
there yeah I can take on age six maybe
I'm sorry but you need yeah but you need
to be cautious the d6 is also falling
now this is an important point but like
I said of course fine here you can be
sure that what would make you yeah
immediately and Joanne Joanne exchange
and two points up so yeah so you need to
be doing to be exact in your in your
calculation if you take on on h 5 / but
you also need to do it's because
otherwise that would be a very fine it's
it's amazing I thought yesterday's gang
was too simple but this is even more
simple it's seeing something a lot of
Club players would have fallen victim to
getting their queen traps especially me
i sometimes a bit adventurous in my
queen okay yeah yeah but it's
oh it's not all the time that that
thinks I need to be hyper complicated
hmm a bit if you if I look for instance
a tad games where where I beat stronger
players it's very often it looks very
one-sided it's not like super
complicated or anything they got into
some some problematic set up and then
one or two in exact moves and and it's
over it's not like you need to produce a
masterpiece to be the strong player it's
the day it just happens sometimes that
the other one is just I'm assessing
something wrong on this calculating
someone even on even on this level it's
it's certainly a bit surprising after
yesterday's game but you could maybe
think that Anand would be a little bit I
don't know shaken up or irritated or
whatever but yeah I had a chave
visualized Gelfand choosing a very solid
drawing strategy just to just to draw
his way to win the match not take any
risks he's you know he's got is you know
money in the bank now to win the match
you know his points he just needed to
just draw his way to win the match
without any risk yeah it was interesting
I was I was also thinking about before
this game where you were what a kind of
opening now you would see i was i was
expecting differ but i think I thought
maybe he will now get his this his main
weapons let's say this usual openings
out like this laughs or yeah Queens
gambit declined due to hunker down to to
get a job yeah but I think it's a very
positive thing that he still played this
rather dynamic opening and it's you also
need to see it the other way if you now
get into some some fried and he would
let's say it would be an open open water
fight and he would win with black then
the match is simply over yeah you're
right so it's just the same if you if
you if you look at football 11 team
escorted gold with you okay I wasn't
gonna mention football Artie I'm sorry
Chelsea yeah I'm sure your parity haha
it's no no no problem
it just adjust the sitting just like a
football you one goal up and you've got
some time to play it's not like when the
85th minutes or something but you've got
some time to play should you're trying
to make the second goal to really to
make it to make it clear or should you
try to play defensively and I'm not not
get a goal very often it's better to to
keep on keep on playing your game and
playing To Your Strengths that he seems
to have decided before that would like
him he wanted to play yeah dynamic
dynamically as the rapids if they had
drawn all the games the rapids would be
a bit like penalties in football it
would just be a lottery wouldn't it but
an end with much greater track record
behind them foot for rapid chess or you
know faster chances yeah it's got a very
very nice also very nice score against
girlfriend in weapons but what what you
always need to need to take into account
that golf on trulia sir well seems to be
a player that really rises to the
occasion yeah you know if it counts he
gives his absolute best and they have
been so many yeah opinions raised before
the match that it would be very
one-sided and he's not I don't know a
worthy challenger or whatever this is
complete nonsense you need to see that
he would what did he do to to get to
this match e you need to to win the
World Cup which is 128 players and
basically everyone played them he played
a lucky number finally played lots of
2700 players on the way to this final
and he beat them all and then he got to
this candidates tournament that he beat
all those guys as well so what what more
can you do I think in terms of what if
you just look at what what did let a
player what he did to play and need to
do to get a match this is for years the
most worthy challenger of all just
compare this with the match two years
ago what to topple of two to get this
work sham pionship match against against
van and if you go all the way back from
2000
turn back then he will got this match
because okay he beat kamsky in this
match to qualify for this but this match
would come ski only got because he lost
to Kramnik in 2006 and it is to
semantics mad she only got because of
Sam Lewis 2005 so you can construct it
all the way back this 2010 much to want
some tournament five years ago and then
you want one match against kamsky become
ski even was the better play and was
just unlucky so it's it's complete
nonsense to tell that this would be
somewhat I don't know an unworthy
challenger or anything of course we all
and I clue myself I would have loved to
see Aronian winning the the candidates
and we see this match yeah but he will
he gives his best and I'll cast for six
matches much games here were pretty dull
but ok we had two exciting games
interesting games now mm-hmm and now
only four games to go maybe we can look
forward to more decisive games here
would be very funny to start with six
drawers and don't have six decisive game
sir my baby girl fan has been practicing
blitz on and he knows it might end up in
business maybe maybe they both have
sorry rapid is it's going to be rapid
40-minute chess with increment or
something yeah yeah but but at the end
if they if they draw all this it's it's
I'm a gun in blitz game at the end or
for all right yeah so the faster time
controls really are an important part of
modern chess to get and but they are not
line it's not just fun anymore blitz
alright yeah sure sure it's a it's very
very important and it's often for very
very high stakes and and breaking this
and also have a good F Kevin good nurse
is very important i'm not sure i did you
yesterday i'm did you see this is
completely off topic no but did you see
the play of rapid match for the US
women's title between another tomski and
your window crush mountains yeah this
was very very entertaining to watch but
i guess for the players it was terrible
ah yeah yeah it was
crash won the first game with black and
they had a 2 2 2 2 2 games yeah and she
won the first game with black and just
needed to draw in the second game with
white and photon ski played very
aggressive opening and had to had a
completely winning position then crushed
blonde at the rook I mean really good
just he just she just needed to to give
one in intermediate check and take it
and it's a rock up and sat on ski stayed
for three minutes into this position and
didn't take the rook and crush was like
oh you could really see it on the webcam
that she was completely oh yeah and then
it continued and sat on ski was winning
anyway she didn't take the route but she
was winning anyway and at the end she
was I don't know so hyped up from honor
that she blundered haruka self haha
really and it was for energy I'm not
sure but it was for thousands of dollars
audi is really a huge prize fund in mum
in those and those US Championships so
rapid and having really am yeah the kind
of nerves what this is it's very very
important nowadays so so arena is arena
crushes the Women's Champion now yeah
yes was it's a good name crush innate
kingscrusher rush right all right yeah
you've gone very much other okay I'm
hoping you are everyone on YouTube still
awake it's still used it I enjoyed this
country I was a brief game sorry about
the detour will try and do the previous
game another time okay uh thanks Chris
thanks every well thanks ok ok see you
in the next game yeah so I don't be here
to better audio this time but I'm pretty
optimistic yeah it worked out well I
think yeah okay Chism she has